un conseil aux parents dont les enfants
se plaignent de leurs instituteurs ou
qu'il leur reproche au contraire de ne
pas être assez sévère avec e.on et les
donc visité le musée de l'éducation de
rond qui vient d'être entièrement rénové
sur plusieurs centaines de mètres carrés
y verront là bas comment du temps des
encriers de la plume sergent major leurs
parents leurs grands parents vivaient
l'école d'alors nicolas lemarignier jean
louis brousse à l'école autrefois
c'était l'enfer c'est du moins l'avis
des enfants qui visitent le musée de
l'éducation mme marois presque un musée
des horreurs
l'institutrice les punitions l'écureuil
tout au long du 19e siècle l'instituteur
est craint par les élèves respecté par
les parents aller en classe c'est un
privilège
l'école obligatoire en 1882 renforce
cette aura le professeur porte les
valeurs de la république dans les
campagnes françaises sur les étagères de
sa classe il range des appareils
scientifiques rutilants qui font la
fierté de l'école républicaine
un siècle plus tard les méthodes ont
changé le modèle pédagogique jugé très
formel très autoritaire de la troisième
république a laissé place à beaucoup
plus de souplesse et a laissé place je
crois à beaucoup plus d'initiatives de
possibilités d'initiative de la part des
enseignants pour tourner la badine n'est
plus qu'un mauvais souvenir
aujourd'hui un écran lumineux et
quelques clics suffisent pour retenir
l'attention des enfants des enfants qui
n'ont plus du tout envie de changer
d'époque à la fin de la visite obligée
par exemple ont envie de bouger
tu veux pas et quand tu y obligerait ses
droits parce que s'il fait un faux pas
ta maîtresse je pense qu'avant avec mais
un coup
il doit alors en faire ou époque
glorieuse
en tout cas la visite pour les enfants
aura été une vraie récréation
effectivement ça se discute